[Music]
now at five we are following breaking
news out of arizona where a tour bus
has crashed i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez officials now
telling us at least one person
is dead dozens more though are hurt let
me show you where it happened
this is along diamond bar grand canyon i
should say on the way to grand canyon
west
and that bus is believed to have
originated from las vegas
david charns joining us now in the
studio and david you've been keeping
close eye on this what can you tell us
yeah denise so this is what we know
right now there were 48 people on board
this bus
as you mentioned on its way from las
vegas to the grand canyon west we do
have a photo to show you from the scene
you see the bus there
in the middle of the road on its side
and if you look at the middle of your
screen there you see the emergency hap
hatch open obviously people escaping
from this crash
and of course lots of responders you see
there on the bend there it looks like in
the road this is where it happened on
diamond bar road
it's about a two-hour drive from where
we are in the valley it's how you get to
what's called grand canyon west and if
you're familiar with the area
that's the attraction where you can walk
out on the skywalk with the
bottom has a glass on it so you can see
all the way down to the bottom
right now this is what we know about who
was on board 48 people
including the driver at least one person
has died
two people airlifted to a hospital here
in the valley in serious condition at
least seven other people
we're told have significant injuries 33
others taken to a hospital
near kingman they have injuries
described as
minor again 48 people on board this bus
that came from the valley rolled over on
its way to grand canyon west right now
we don't know the name of the local
company that owns the bus
we are working to bring you lots more
information both on air and online and
we do have a crew on the way to the
scene
for now i'm david charns 8 news now